what was your last conversation like  with Carrie um well I saw her in  November for her birthday  and we had a grand time the typical  Carrie party and and then my last  conversation which which I did write  about in an article that that went viral  I wrote I saved the text messages they  were from the night before she got on  her fateful flight and I've saved them  screenshotted backed them up on to draw  you know other hard drives because you  know I don't ever want to lose them but  we talked about politics we talked about  our mothers who were frail both of them  and our children and promised to see  each other at Christmas which I have  held I was there with her yeah maybe she  wasn't I think she knew I was there  [Music]  you